there's someone here where I
don't know keep your eye open
Logan
wait
I am so sorry
Welcome back everyone Happy New Year this will
be my video for The Wolverine Spider-Man X-Men
crossover scene that you've probably heard
about in the past maybe you've seen it before
but there's been a lot of talk about them
crossing over in secret Wars and then paying
off this deleted scene from way back in the
first X-Men movie that's kind of been Kevin
feige's thing is paying things off and the funny
thing is that this deleted scene took place at
a final battle at the Statue of Liberty and
they kind of had a big crossover scene with
the Multiverse in Spider-Man no way home at the
Statue of Liberty this scene also goes back to
the origin of Kevin feige at Marvel Studios way
back in the 90s so if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up next
week we're also getting a brand new Ant-Man and
the Wasp quantumania trailer video we're supposed
to be seeing the first version of MODOK in the
MCU during that as well too of course I will do
videos for everything but the deleted scene here
of Spider-Man with Wolverine and the X-Men was
featured as a secret bonus clip on the original
X-Men movie box DVD sets the the funny thing is
that fox didn't put this deleted scene on the
normal home video releases because they didn't
want to get sued out of existence by Sony because
of the circumstances for how they use Spider-Man
in that original X-Men movie it was kind of like
a double secret probation deleted scene and they
thought that enough time had gone by when they
released it finally like many years later after
the movie had come out that they hoped that
Sony's lawyers wouldn't care about it at that
point and talk about Multiverse because right
after this they did work out some of the rights
issues between Fox and Sony and they were going
to have Hugh Jackman have a cameo walk-on role
in the Spider-Man 2002 Tobey Maguire movie that
time it was going to be more legit Hugh Jackman
even said that Kevin foggy had to remind him of
it years later the reason why it didn't happen
though is because they actually had a practical
issue with the Wolverine costume at the time
and it wasn't ready in time for them to film the
scene that they were going to film with him in the
Spider-Man movie sort of you can see the wheels
spinning in the back of Kevin foggy's mind like
we have to cross all these characters over can
this happen and you guys look it's not going to
be easy because you're working with different
Studios and their properties but I believe
maybe I'm optimistic I understand a Marvel
they've got Avengers they've got a lot of
big things going on but at some point I just find
it almost impossible there's not a way to bring
Iron Man all the Avengers characters you know
Wolverine the X-Men characters Spider-Man and
somehow get them in together but I'm in for it
I'm totally up for it because I think that would
be really exciting for fans across the board but
during the original X-Men 2000 movie during the
final battle when Wolverine the X-Men come to the
Statue of Liberty to save Rogue stop Magneto from
trying to activate the X genes of everyone
on the planet turning them on to mutants too
they face Magneto's Brotherhood of mutants toad
Sabertooth Mystique Mystique uses her ability to
disguise herself as a couple different characters
the one that wound up in the actual movie was her
pretending to be a version of Wolverine to confuse
them but during this extended version of the fight
scene this deleted scene a version of Spider-Man
just drops in casually if you couldn't hear his
dialogue very clearly he runs in behind them and
yells wait and then seemingly realizes he's on
the wrong movie Set apologizing to everyone as he
slowly backs away Wolverine the rest of the X-Men
I'll break character briefly there were a couple
reasons why Spider-Man wound up in this film like
yes they wanted to have a big Crossover with all
the Marvel characters but the rights at that point
like we're talking about the early 2000s here
late 90s when they were filming this the rights
were a mess at that point it also kind of started
out just as a gag like a joke because there was
so much money and so much time being spent on
this new X-Men movie it was basically Meant To
Be The Rebirth of comic book movies in the wake of
Batman Returns because everybody remembered what
a big flop that had been had been super campy
people didn't take comic book movies seriously
anymore one of the few exceptions to that was
the blade movie also in the late 90s but you
have to remember that Studios because of things
like Batman Returns were so afraid of people not
taking this new X-Men movie seriously the Brian
Singer the fox people wanted to treat it super
seriously Kevin feige even joked that on this set
Brian Singer had banned the actors from Reading
comic books because he didn't want it to feel like
a comic book movie that's why all their costumes
were the black leather ones instead of the classic
more colorful costumes there was even a joke about
that during the movie about the quote-unquote
yellow spandex like the classic Wolverine suit
I actually go outside in these things what would
you prefer yellow spandex oh how Time Has Changed
things now all we want is to see Wolverine in that
classic yellow costume during Deadpool 3. and you
have to remember that while they were filming
this scene here with Spider-Man in the original
X-Men movie this was 1999 when they were filming
it Sony was still getting ready to hire Sam Raimi
like they hadn't hired him yet they were still
working on the script for Toby Maguire Spider-Man
movie and they had not yet hired Toby Maguire
so even though Sony knew that it was going to
try and make a Spider-Man movie they didn't know
exactly what it was going to look like they didn't
know who the actor was going to be which is why in
this scene here Spider-Man's costume doesn't look
anything like Tobey Maguire's suit he wasn't cast
till the year after this scene was filmed in 2000
they probably had some concept Dart for tobium
Maguire's version at this point but it was still
of them trying to figure out what that movie
was going to look like so the Spider-Man 2002
movie didn't really exist yet the actor playing
Spider-Man in this scene is named Scott laba who
had originally been one of the contenders just
plays Spider-Man when they had tried to make a
Spider-Man movie way back in the 1980s when Canon
films held the rites they were the same people
that made the Christopher Reeve Superman movies so
this would have been them making their version of
a Spider-Man movie right after Superman 4 had come
out in theaters eventually the riots passed to
Columbia Pictures which is how James Cameron got
on the project you have a whole different history
with James Cameron's version of the Spider-Man
movie that he tried to make in the 90s before
Titanic this is some concept art for what his
version of Spider-Man would have looked like it
would have been Leonardo DiCaprio as you'd expect
because he would have been the perfect age to play
a teenage Spider-Man during the 90s but the funny
thing is is that on that original X-Men movie
Kevin feige got his start as sort of like the
baby version of Kevin feige at Marvel Studios if
you don't remember Kevin feige originally started
out as the assistant to Lauren Shula daughter and
Richard daughter who made the original Superman
movie by the time they gotten ready to make Brian
singers X-Men 2000 movie he'd become her assistant
producer and he became like the Studio's man on
set just watching things making sure the trains
moved on time he said that at the time he was
like the low man on the the totem pole he had
absolutely no power he couldn't tell anybody
what he thought that they should be doing on the
movie like how they should make it that was still
a long ways off Hugh Jackman told jokes about how
Kevin feige snuck him Wolverine Comic books on set
to help him inform his character because remember
Brian Singer had banned comic books on the set of
the movie he continued working on the X-Men movies
he also served as an assistant producer on the
Spider-Man movies with Toby Maguire Sam Raimi he
became the CEO of Marvel Studios as you know today
in 2003 while they were working on Spider-Man 2
and just like there were a bunch of Rights issues
with Spider-Man showing up in this original X-Men
movie Kevin feige had the exact same problem when
he went on to make the first Iron Man movie that
was really famous deleted scene of Nick Fury in
that post-credits scene from the first Iron Man
film where he shouts out mutants X-men Spider-Man
all these characters that he wanted to cross over
in the upcoming Marvel movies they were planning
on making as if gamma accidents radioactive
bug bites and assorted mutants weren't enough
I have to deal with a spoiled brat who doesn't
play well with others he wants to keep all his
toys to himself so the funny thing about that is
in that version of his plan initially like you
can see he wanted to have versions of Toby
Maguire Spider-Man crossover into the MCU
he wanted versions of the X-Men characters to
cross over he also wanted to have a version of
Wolverine crossover in the first Captain America
movie because the whole idea is that Logan is so
long-lived he was around during World War II as
a regular Soldier before he became the Wolverine
character Hugh Jackman would have shown up in
this scene here where Captain America shows up
to save all the pows in The Howlin Commandos he
would have just been one of the random prisoners
that was being held captive here but at the time
they were getting ready to film that scene in the
first Captain America movie they were getting
ready to make the Wolverine Origins movie The
Wolverine character had become so popular at Fox
and so valuable to them they were like absolutely
not you cannot borrow any of our characters oh
how times have changed now we're finally getting
Hugh Jackman crossing over into the MCU through
Deadpool 3. in a lot of the reason why people
are talking about Wolverine Spider-Man Toby
Maguire crossing over together on screen is
because they're actually going to do a version
of that during Avengers Secret Wars pay off
all these big crossover scenes like the Iron
Man one post-credits scene the original X-Men
2000 crossover scene when Hugh Jackman meets
the version of Toby Maguire's Spider-Man and
they fight Kang together the other big rumor
you may have heard too is that during Secret
Wars the version of Kang that they wind up
fighting will actually be the beyonder and
they'll use more Easter eggs from the original
1980s Secret Wars because it was the beyonder
pulling them all to a version of battle world
and the plot was very different from the more
modern version of secret words and that beyonder
will just be another Kang variant not the kang
the Conqueror variant that we see in Ant-Man the
Wasp quantumania I believe he is going to be the
version that we see in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
and then when we get to Secret Wars that's when
it's the beyonder variant of Kang if we hear
about them paying off any more long-running
deleted scenes or really cool deleted ideas that
they had during these original movies of course
I'll include them in videos but that's kind of
the thing that they're doing during Secret Wars
is they had all these cool ideas back during the
early 2000s even back as early as the 1980s that
they just weren't able to do for copyright reasons
or there were production issues they just didn't
have the technology at the time now they can do
crazy versions of all that stuff everyone click
here for my Deadpool 3 Wolverine trailer video
and click here to learn about Ben Affleck coming
back to the Marvel movies thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and Happy New Year!